et voilà je te fais un e et comme ça ça
va tenir
ça doit saluer c'est parfait
heureusement que tu m'as aidé je
n'aurais jamais pu accrocher tout ça
dans leur tour de sabrina vous arriver
bonjour salies vous savez que vous
tombez bien je nous attendons casimir
qui va nous lire un poème qu'il a écrit
lui-même ce formidable ça sera un très
beau poème certainement parce que
casimir est très sensible et très fin
maintien le voilà ton et refrain est
sensible à mont joli
bonjour françois alors tu as écris ton
poème oui haili même très joli c'est
formidable tu va nous le dire tout de
suite ap les offenses venir et coire
casimir adouberaient complètement bien
corrélé nous tu fais dans la halle et là
oui oui allez on a écouté non l'intérêt
mais doit près de l'arbre
voilà voilà
allez on t'écoute ben non qu'est-ce
qu'il a peints vous êtes trop loin bon
ben on se rapproche à l'est corinne jean
phi 6 ans venait la dose alors là vous
êtes trop près ça vous êtes trop premier
retrait valeur refuge qu'il mangeait là
là bas voilà la partie asseyez-vous avec
julie c est bien la cuisine et non
qu'est-ce qui l'a pas encore mais j'ai
oublié le premier mot de mon poème et
cherche et cèpes souvenir c'est une
partie de la tête
bon ben c'est high cerveau joue non mais
non dans d'or palatin bardon alors
l'essayer dans notre île
un bravo bravo curieuse conception de
l'orthographe
nos peurs vas-y dans notre île aux
enfants
casimir un charmant
quand une voix rogge celle de monsieur
du snob qui te rend si hardy de problème
on breuvage dit cet animal plein de rage
tue ce rachat fier de ta témérité le
châtier mois casimir monsieur du snob me
fait bien rire et je préfère le matin
aller voir mes amis la fin les petits
lapins dans le bois folâtre sur l'herbe
arrosée et comme nous le vin d'arbois
ils boivent la douce rosée au mois deux
sus de la des choses amusantes mais
certaines me semble un peu trop
étonnante une fourmi de 18 m avec un
chapeau sur la tête ça n'existe pas le
tour me traînant un char plein de
pingouins et de canards ça n'existe pas
mais un spectacle aussi n'étonne que
l'on peut voir à chaque automne à
l'enterrement d'une feuille morte le
escargots s'en vont ils ont la coquille
noir du creps autour des cornes
moi j'ai la couleur orange et je suis
aussi bouquin est dit et enfants j'ai
entendu ce qu'il a dit n'est pas
l'impression que certaines parties de
son poème ont été écrites par quelqu'un
d'autre
1 entre autres
tu sais ce qu'ils valent casimir qui va
nous redire tout un poème par petits
morceaux et à chacun de ses pas ces
petits morceaux du tarp et on verra
c'est toi quelqu'un d'autre d'accord bon
casimir on écoute dans notre île aux
enfants
casini a très charmant entend une voix
rogge celle de monsieur du snob
bon c'est de qui ça à votre avis
ces deux qui de kazim ou de quelqu'un
d'autre et bien c'est du casimir casimir
continue qui tord aussi hardy de
troubler mon breuvage dit cet animal
plein de rage tue sera châtié de ta
témérité
là tu vois c'est un cri unanime ça c'est
un petit peu tricheurs c'est de la fonte
elle allait reprendre mot châtié mois
casimir monsieur du snop me fait bien
rire et je préfère le matin aller voir
mes amis lapin c'est de qui ça c'est du
casino casimir continue les petits
lapins dans le bois sur la trt sur
l'herbe arrosée et comme nous le vin
d'arbois
ils boivent la douce rosée 7 à la
fontaine
c'est à jacques prévert c2t dehors de
deauville
casimir poursuivre on voit de ci de là
des choses amusantes mais certains ne me
semble un peu trop étonnante ce petit
passage la jeunesse est dans le style
c'est du style casino évidemment aller
casimir continue une fourmi de 18 m avec
un chapeau sur la tête ça n'existe pas
une fourmi traînant un char plein de
pingouins et de canards ça n'existe pas
alors non ça c'est pas casimir justement
c'est pas la fontaine c'est robert
desnos casimir poursuit mais un
spectacle aussi m'étonne que l'on peut
voir à chaque automne
c'est encore du casimir continue à
l'enterrement tu ne veuilles ou mort
deux escargots s'en vont ils ont la
coquille noir du creps où tous les
cornes
alors la lumière jean christian st
jacques
c'est de jacques prévert et bien-être
dans casimir la fin moi j'ai la peau
couleur orange et je suis aussi doux
qu'un ange
ça c'est du quasi muet mais casimir tu
sais j'exagère un petit peu tu n'as même
pas écrit la moitié de nos poèmes mais
c'est quand même pas mal pour mon âge